we have a new bt a calendar
it's a new month happy november
everybody i'm really excited to have a
new BTW a calendar i've been using my
calendar for all of october as you can
see here and it's time for november the
start I've taken a lot of the feedback
that you guys have given me for the
people who test drove it for me and I've
compiled it and made the new one I think
even better and I'm looking for I'm
going to expand this one the first one
was ten I'm looking for 20 people now 20
people who want to help me test drive
the new version of it the first 20
people to leave a comment below will get
a free link to the PDF copy to hopefully
give me some feedback ideas and how we
can make the BTA calendar even better
the idea what this is it not only helps
you stay on track of what your BTW a
number is for the channel but also helps
to stay focused on the goals that you
want to accomplish in your business and
in your life and what I found with
habits is when you have your day start
off with a positive habit you're much
more likely to keep to all the other
habits where if you start off a day and
you miss your habit you're much more
likely to not follow through on the
other things right so if you sleep in
late you're less likely to work out
you're less likely to eat healthy you
like throw off that day and second i'm
going to start over tomorrow so the idea
with the BTA calendar is it acts as a
lightning rod for you to be able to
accomplish the things that you want to
accomplish not just on your business but
also in your life and your regular
habits so first 20 people who lose a
comment gets free access the caveat is
you got to give me feedback on how
you're using it what could be better
ready
and go